I wonder if you can speak to the the
bureaucracy the political battles the
scientific battles for for time on the
James blood telescope is there a there
must be a fascinating it's process of
scheduling that all scientists are
trying to collaborate and figure out
what the most important problems are
and there's an interesting network of
interfering scientific experiments
probably have to somehow optimize over
it's it's a really difficult process I
don't envy the attack that are going to
have to make this decision we call it
the attack the time allocation committee
that they make this decision
um and I've served on these before and
it's very difficult I mean typically for
Hubble we we were seeing at least 10
sometimes 20 times the number of
proposals for telescope time versus
available telescope time for did youst
there has been one call already that has
gone out we call it cycle one and that
was oversubscribed by I think something
like six to one seven to one and uh the
cycle two which is just been announced
uh fairly recently and the deadline is
actually the end of this month so my
team are totally laser focused on
writing our proposals right now
um that is expected to be much more
competitive probably more comparable to
what Hubble saw and so it's hard more
competitive than the second one you said
already because that's already super
competitive in the first cycle so I said
the first cycle of James Webb was about
six to one
um and this will probably be more like
20 to one I would so these are all
proposals by scientists and so on and
it's not like you can schedule at any
time because if you're looking for
transit times yeah you have you have a
time critical element yes time critical
development and they're conflicting in
non-like non-obvious ways because
they're the the frequency is different
uh the duration is different right and
it's because it's probably computational
needs yeah there are different uh that
there's the type of sensors the
direction pointing all that yeah it's
hard and there are certain programs like
doing a deep field study where you just
more or less point the telescope and
that's pretty open I mean you're just
accumulating photons you can just point
at that at that patch of the sky
um whenever the telescope's not doing
anything else and just get to your month
let's say months of integration time is
your is your goal over the lifetime of
jbst so that's maybe a little bit easier
to schedule it's harder especially for
us looking at cool worlds
um because as I said earlier these these
plants Transit very infrequently
so we have to wait if you're looking at
the Earth translating the Sun an alien
watching us they they would only get one
opportunity per year to do that
observation the transit lasts for about
12 hours
um and so if they don't get that time
it's hard that's it if it conflicted
with another proposal that wants to do
use the another time critical element
it's much easier for plants like uh
these hot these hot plants with these
close implants because they Transit so
frequently there's maybe a hundred
opportunities and so then the tax can
say okay they want 10 transits there's a
hundred opportunities here it's easier
for us to give us to give them time
we're almost in the worst case scenario
we're proposing to look for examines
around two cool planets and so we really
only have one bite of the Cherry for
each one and so our sales pitch has been
that these are extremely precious events
and more importantly gwst is the only
telescope the only machine Humanity has
ever constructed acid which is capable
of finding moons akin to the moon's in
our solar system Kepler can't do it even
Hubble can't do it generously is the
first one and so there is a new window
to the universe because we know these
moons exist they they're all over the
place in the solar system you have the
moon you have IO Callisto Europa
Ganymede Titan lots of moons are fairly
similar size sort of 30 the size of the
Earth and this telescope is the first
one that can find them and so we're very
excited about the profound implications
of
ultimately solving this journey we're on
in astronomy which is to understand our
uniqueness we want to understand how
common is the solar system are we the
way are we the architecture that
frequently emerges naturally or is there
something special about what happened
here I think this is not the worst case
the best case it's obvious it's super
rare so you have to like I would so I
love scheduling from a computer science
perspective that's my background so
algorithmically to solve a schedule
problem I will schedule the rarest
things first and obviously this is the
the jwst is the first thing that can
actually detect a cool world so this is
a big new thing you can show off that
new thing happens rarely schedule it
first it's perfect you should be in the
attack
I'll file my application after I've done
with this I I you know this part of me
is the OCD part of me is the
computational aspect I love scheduling
uh Computing device because you have
that kind of scheduling
on super computers on that scheduling
problem is fascinating how do you
prioritize computational how do you
prioritize science uh data collection uh
sample collection all that kind of stuff
it's actually kind of it's kind of
fascinating because data in ways you
expect and don't expect will unlock a
lot of solutions to uh some fascinating
Mysteries and so collecting the data and
doing so in a way that maximizes the
possibility of Discovery is really
interesting like from a computational
perspective I agree there's a real
satisfaction extracting the maximum
science per unit time yeah exactly out
of your telescope and that that's that's
the tax job um but the the attack are
not machines they're not a piece of
computer code
um they will make their selections based
off human judgment and
um a lot of the telescope is certainly
within the field of exoplanets because
there's different fields of astronomy
but within the field of exoplans I think
a good expectation is that most of the
telescope time that James jersey have
will go towards atmospheric retrieval
which is uh sort of alluded to earlier
you know like detecting molecules in the
atmospheres not by signatures because as
I said it's really not designed to do
that it's pushing jrst probably too far
to expect to do that but it could detect
for example a carbon dioxide Rich
atmosphere on trappist-1e that's not a
buyer signature but you could prove it's
like a Venus in that case or maybe like
a Mars in that case like both those have
carbon dioxide Rich atmospheres doesn't
prove or disprove the existence of life
either way but it is our first
characterization of the nature of those
atmospheres maybe we can even tell the
pressure level and the temperature of
those atmospheres so that's very
exciting but um there's we are competing
with that and that I I think that
science is completely mind-blowing and
fantastic we have a completely different
objective which is in our case to try
and look for the first evidence of these
small moons around these planets
um potentially even moons which could be
habitable of course so I think it's a
very exciting goal but
um attack has to make a human judgment
essentially about which science are they
most excited by which one has the
highest promise of return the most
highest chance of return and so that's
hard because if you look at a planetary
atmosphere
well you know most time the plant has an
atmosphere already it and so there's
almost a guaranteed success that you're
going to learn something about the
Atmosphere by pointing wst at it whereas
in our case there's a harder cell we are
looking for something that we do not
know for sure exists yet or not and so
we are pushing the telescope to do
something which is inherently more risky
yeah but the existence is shown already
gives a deep
a lesson about what's out there in the
universe but that means that other stars
have similar types of variety as we have
in our solar system they have an IO they
have a Europa and so on which means like
there's a lot of possibility
for Icy planets for water for plants
that enable for planets and moves that I
mean that that's super exciting because
that that means everywhere through our
galaxy and Beyond
there's just innumerable possibility for
weird creatures I agree life forms you'd
have to convince me I mean yeah NASA has
been on this quest for a long time and
it's sometimes called eater Earth it's
the frequency of Earth like usually they
say planets in the universe how common
are plants similar to our Earth in terms
of
um ultimately we'd like to know
everything about these plants in terms
of the amount of water they have how
much atmosphere they have but for now
it's kind of focused just on the size
and the distance from the Star
essentially how how often do you get
similar conditions to that
um that was Kepler's primary Mission and
it it really just kind of flirted with
the answer it didn't quite get to a
definitive answer but I always say look
if we're looking if that's our primary
goal to look for Earth-like
I would say worlds then moons has to be
a part of that because we know that um
Earth-like and from the capital data the
preliminary Resort is the Earth-like
planets around sunlight stars is not
an inevitable outcome it seems to be
something like a one to ten percent
outcome so it's not particularly
inevitable that happens but we do often
see about half of awesome like stars
have either a mini Neptune a Neptune or
Jupiter in hablo zone of Their Stars
that's a very very common occurrence
that we see yet we have no idea how
often they have moons around them which
could also be habitable and so there may
very well be if even one in five of them
has an Earth-like moon or even a Mars
like Moon around them then there would
be more habitable real estate in terms
of EXO moons than exoplanets you can
essentially 2x 3x 5x maybe 10x the
number of habitable worlds out there in
the universe our current estimate like
the Drake equation absolutely yeah so
this this is a one way to increase the
confidence
and increase the the value of that
parameter and just know where to look I
mean we we would like to know where
should we listen for techno signatures
where should we be looking for buyer
signatures
um and not only that but what role does
the does the moon have in terms of its
influence on the planet
um we talked about these directly image
telescopes earlier these missions that
want to take a photo to quote Carl Sagan
The Pale Blue Dart of our planet but the
pale blue dot of an exoplanet and that's
the dream to one day capture that but as
impressive as the resolution is that we
are planning and conspiring to design
for the future generation telescopes to
achieve that even those telescopes will
not have the capability of resolving the
Earth and the moon within that it'll be
a pale blue dot pixel but the moon's
gray grayness will be intermixed with
that pixel and so this is a big problem
because one of the ways that we are
claiming to look for life in the
universe is a chemical disequilibrium
so you see two molecules that just
shouldn't be there they normally react
with each other or even one molecule
that's just too reactive to be hanging
around the Atmosphere by itself so if
you had oxygen and methane hanging out
together those would normally react
fairly easily and so if you detected
those two molecules in your pale blue
dot Spectra you bet okay we have
evidence for life something's
metabolizing on this planet
um however the challenge here is what if
that moon was Titan Titan has a
methane-rich atmosphere and what if the
pale blue dot was in fact a plant devoid
of life but it had oxygen because of
water undergoing its photolysis reaction
splitting into oxygen hydrogen
separately so then you have all of the
Hallmarks of what we would claim to be
life but all along you were tricked it
was just a moon that was deceiving you
and so we are never going to we're never
going to I would claim really understand
the
or complete this quest of looking for
Life by signatures in the universe
unless we have a deep knowledge of the
prevalence and role that moons have they
may even affect the habitability of the
planets themselves of course Iran moon
is freakishly large by mass ratio it's
the largest moon in the solar system
it's a one percent Mass Moon if you look
at Jupiter's moons they're like 10 to
the power minus four much smaller and so
I wrote moon seems to stabilize the
obliquity of our planet it gives rise to
Tides especially early on when the moon
was closer those tires would have
covered entire continents and those
those Rock pools that would have been
scattered across the entire Plateau may
have been the origin of Life on our
planet the moon forming impact may have
stripped a significant fraction of
lithosphere of the earth which without
it plate tectonics may not have been
possible we'd heard a stagnant lid
because it was just too much lithosphere
stuck on the top of the of the planet
and so there are speculative reasons but
intriguing reasons as to why a large
Moon
Maybe
not just important but Central to the
question of having the conditions
necessary for life so moons can be
habitable in their own right but they
can also play significant influence on
the habitability of the planets they
orbit and further they will surely
interfere with our attempts to detect
life remotely from afar